Folks, in 2022, we know
capitalism has a problem.
The system that undergirds
much of our way of life in the West
is exacerbating injustice and inequality.
We know that women
still get paid less than men.
This is 2022.
And the share of the bottom half
of the world’s population and wealth
is just two percent.
We know that the playing field
is not level.
And yet, even as we are awash
in new ideas and thinking and approaches,
technologies and gadgets,
we somehow do not seem to know
how to address the fundamental problems
at the heart of it all.
Now I can’t claim to have all the answers,
but today I want
to talk to you about a tool
that can help us design more just systems.
And that tool is moral clarity.
Now, moral clarity is not an ideology.
It's not righteousness.
Moral clarity is doing the right thing
because it is right
and not from fear of sanction
or an expectation of reward.
It is clarity of the demands
that we are allowed to make of others.
It is to never confuse
what we ought to do with what we can do.
No one ought to starve.
No one ought to be discriminated against.
No one ought to profit from suffering.
These are not personal preferences.
These are moral imperatives
that most people believe in --
(Applause)
whatever their politics or culture.
And this is what gives us the basis
to build more just
organizations, communities
and, ultimately, a more just world.
So, folks, how do we do it?
First, if we want justice,
let's use the language of justice,
the language of right and wrong.
Take stakeholder capitalism,
this notion that a company
is responsible to all its stakeholders
and to the environment,
and not just its shareholders.
How well has it done?
Well, we have data
that shows that as a group,
companies that subscribe
to stakeholder capitalism
did no better supporting
their employees in the pandemic
than companies that made no such pledge.
Why?
It’s not because
stakeholder capitalism is a charade
or its ends are not noble
or its metrics broken
or incentives misaligned.
It's because we have been selling
stakeholder capitalism
as a way to reduce risk
and ensure long-term growth and profits.
Take, for instance:
Why should a workplace be diverse?
And this is what I hear all the time:
“So it better reflects our customers,
allowing us to build better products,
so we can improve retention,
so we can increase innovation and profit.”
Alright. But what if you already
have record-setting profits?
What if your products
are already all the rage?
What [about] when there are far easier
alternatives to increasing profits
than the difficult work
of organizational change?
What then?
What then will motivate us
to stay the course?
So, folks, I need you.
Let’s come together
and set the narrative straight.
Here, let's say this loud and clear.
We want every workplace to affirm women,
minorities and every group
that is underrepresented --
not in expectation of more innovation
or profit or retention,
but because it is the right thing to do.
It is the just thing to do,
because that is what we ought to do.
(Applause)
Now, I’m not minimizing the difficulty
of organizational change.
I run an organization.
I understand the competing
demands and priorities.
Reconciling what we ought to do
with what we can do
is necessarily imperfect.
Moral clarity is not moral perfection.
It is moral alertness.
I'm also not minimizing or saying
that innovation or better products
or retention are not worthy goals.
My point is, let's start making space
in our organizations for moral language
and clear moral arguments.
Now --
(Applause)
There was a time in America
when you could start as a custodian
or in the mail room
and rise through the ranks,
even to the top job.
Now that doesn't happen anymore.
We have outsourced those jobs.
We have turned them into gig work.
And the problem is not just
the low wages or poor benefits
or the unpredictable working hours.
The problem is we know nothing,
nothing about the lives of so many
who make our own possible.
We don't know that the worker
in our cafeteria is sleeping in her car
so she can work three jobs
to send her kids to college.
We don't know that the worker
in our warehouse
has uncontrolled diabetes,
even though he has health insurance.
But he doesn't have the time
to manage this chronic condition.
Folks, how can we be just
if these indignities are hidden from us,
if they don't show up in our accounting?
How can lives matter, truly matter to us,
if you only read about them?
If you don’t encounter them?
If you don’t share in their humanity?
So, it shouldn’t take a hot labor market
for us to invest
in our entry-level employees.
And let's not stop
at tuition subsidies and training.
Let's do the harder work
of mentoring those
who do not show up
on our organizational charts.
Let's understand their aspirations
and connect them to opportunities,
even if those are outside our firms.
Next.
Let's get rid of the idea that a smart app
or gadget or technology or business model
will fix injustice.
It will not!
(Applause)
Justice requires accompaniment,
staying by a person's side
until right is done.
I started a nonprofit
that provides health care
to the rural poor in India,
and we realized very early on
that we could have all the therapeutics
and health care workers and facilities,
but we would not transform outcomes
until we accompanied
literally our patients.
So, in our maternal
and neonatal health program,
expectant mothers have us on speed dial.
They call us as soon as
they go into labor,
and we stay beside them, literally,
till they make it
to the delivery room in time.
Why? Because the barriers
are too numerous to predict.
Flooded roads, an unwilling patriarch,
a labor nurse who will not assist
a woman of another caste.
And that is why we journey
to distant cities if we have to,
and we find a neonatal ICU
and stay by the side
of an anxious mother and her newborn
until they are both well.
And that is how we have cut
mortality rates in half in our program
when everyone around us
told us that it was impossible.
(Applause)
Accompaniment is not
just about health care.
In the United States,
low-income students drop out
of community colleges at record rates
because of the barriers they face.
They may not have the fare
for public transport to attend classes.
They may not have the child care
to make it to a job interview.
They may be struggling
with homelessness or hunger.
Now, financial assistance is crucial,
and we need more of it.
But it will not by itself
transform outcomes.
What we also need are seasoned advisors
who can accompany our students,
who can help them pick majors and classes,
teach them study techniques,
provide career counseling and help them
juggle home, work and college.
And now we have rigorous evidence
that these accompaniment-centered
interventions
that address a whole array of barriers
can double graduation rates.
This is from the City University
of New York's ASAP initiative.
Accompaniment is not just for nonprofits.
As we try to reimagine
and reconfigure work
and inclusion
in the wake of the pandemic,
accompaniment is that principled approach
that can get us there.
Now, for all of these ideas
to take root and endure,
we need to make moral clarity foundational
to our educational system.
A recent college poll showed
that graduating college students
consider working
for social change less likely
than they did as freshmen.
Our students spend all their time
becoming skilled specialists.
They accrue credentials for everything --
everything except for the difficult work
of making the world just.
I teach a course,
Entrepreneurship for the Idealist,
at Princeton University,
which trains students in moral clarity
so they can go out
and make the world just.
We can teach our students
the language of right and wrong
and give them the courage to use it.
We can teach them the nature of injustice
so they have a fighting chance
at dismantling it.
And we can train them in accompaniment.
We don't expect families to train
humanists or scientists or engineers.
So let's stop making moral clarity
the sole responsibility
of families or of religion.
(Applause)
Now, some of you may be thinking
that all of this is too hard.
That this is unrealistic.
And I can understand that.
I've been doing this a long time.
Let's stop worrying about being realistic.
(Applause)
Last year, folks,
we invested 621 billion dollars
globally in startups,
in dreams, in visions,
in visions of worlds
transformed by new technologies,
in visions of planets colonized
and of alternate universes.
Now, many of those dreams will fail.
Many of those dreams
will take decades to materialize.
But will we flinch?
No, we'll double down.
Such is our faith in those visions.
Folks, if we are trying
to do something truly hard,
I want us to come together
to do the hardest thing there is:
envision and then build a just world.
Not a prosperous world.
Not a frictionless world.
Not a resilient world, but a just world.
(Applause)
Now in our time, the call
to do the right thing because it is right,
because it is just,
evokes a certain wistfulness.
It has that quality
of a once-beloved melody
whose notes now elude us.
We are worried that if we sing the tune,
it's going to land
just a bit flat in our time.
And the reason is
the foundational myth
of our political and economic systems
that people will do only that
which is advantageous to them.
So while we never shun our idealism,
it's a stubborn thing we learn early on
to wear it lightly.
Folks, let's stop selling ourselves short.
We are capable of being small,
but we are not small beings.
We help strangers whom we know
we will never see again.
We grieve.
We grieve for strangers
who are oceans away.
In the expectation of what reward
are Polish mothers leaving their strollers
on train stations
so Ukrainian mothers fleeing,
dispossessed and broken,
will find some respite?
Yes, we are driven by incentives.
But we are also driven by love,
mercy, kindness, justice, solidarity.
Folks,
I have an abiding faith in our idealism,
in mine and in yours. And here’s why.
Our pursuits may be different,
our politics may be different,
our motivations will always be many.
But our deepest longing
has always been the same:
to find our humanity,
to fathom that magnificent vastness
within each of us.
Thank you.
(Applause)